three two one we have ignition and
liftoff
last Friday's SpaceX resupply launch
might have looked like any other take
off but aboard the rocket was a very
special guest meet Simon the newest team
member aboard the International Space
Station the name is short for crew
interactive mobile companion
despite his smiling face it's the inside
that counts
Simon's the first demonstration of
artificial intelligence created to
support astronauts aboard the station
built by Airbus for the German DLR space
administration
Simon was specifically configured to
work with German astronaut Alexander
Gerst for this mission he will assist
him during two different tasks so we
will be able to provide him with the
good advices during complex procedures
as well as system and social interaction
or by social interaction Simon's name
was inspired by a character from the
1940s captain future science fiction
novels open the pod bay doors hell but
when you think about AI in space I'm
afraid I can't do that a less friendly
intelligent system named Hal from
Stanley Kubrick's 2001 a Space Odyssey
come to mind this mission is too
important for me to allow you to
jeopardize it Simon can see hear and
speak should I contact the ground
station while his capabilities are
somewhat limited right now he can still
perform tasks such as explaining
experiments and serving as an early
warning system for technical issues
thanks to 12 internal fans
Simon is also mobile a big part of this
experiment is to see how artificial
intelligence might help for future
long-distance missions if you go with
six to eight people to Mars or in any
long-term mission the science groups
already think about the good
countermeasures against play
psychological
reactions which will appear during that
kind of flight just amazing Simon looks
very friendly more friendly than how
well what's interesting is that
researchers toyed around with a more
humanoid face but they felt that a
spherical ball with a kind of standard
look like that would be less creepy that
folks up there was comforting decrease
the howl factor a little bit but well he
does have a hard shut off to in case
controlling he tries to become how